let's talk about the pretenders because
such a revolutionary such a
revolutionary band whether you intended
it to be or not you're in the band
because it's good yeah three guys and I
think we have a picture here of the
classic this is the lineup Pete barn din
Martin chambers
James Honeyman Scott yeah did you guys
always I was very impressed that some
bands might especially at that time or
even today might tout oh it's a woman
it's a it's a gender thing that was
never interested interesting to you like
you didn't care it didn't seem like
anyone in the band cared this is a woman
where men are there man I'm a woman yeah
no you know I think it's a myth that's
created outside of music because you
know in music people just want to it's
about the sound and as long as
everyone's sounding like they want to
sound everyone's happy with that and you
know I was good at bringing out the best
in those guys so they were just glad for
that and the gender thing they probably
thought it was a pain in the ass to be
honest I'm sure they did but you know
you know bad was great yeah I was I was
a great band leader he I mean we'd do
television and my hair would be sticking
out in the back and then later I'd see a
clip and I think wow I didn't even tell
me that and I knew they were all having
a you know a laugh at my expense but you
know what's funny is the you when MTV
first launched you the pretenders were
on heavy rotation tons of hits great
videos but you weren't comfortable with
that see the it looked like there was a
lot of English fans making videos when
MTV started but it's because in England
there was these kids shows and sometimes
you couldn't make it to do the kid show
so we made little clips to put on the
kids shows then MTV started and everyone
the only people that had made these
clips were English fans so it looked
like there was an invasion I never knew
that yeah all the early ones were
predominantly English that's only
because we made them for all these kids
just his waz and other shows but we
hated it and we weren't comfortable
because we thought when we got in bands
that you could just be ugly and be on a
band and first of all you're six foot
taller than anyone else cuz you're
already you're used to that but you're
we're all real all ready on a stage so
people are looking up so you don't
really have to have confidence they're
already looking up and but it's kind of
a bluff and you didn't have to worry
about how you look too much because
they're kind of far away and suddenly it
was videos and everyone got right up
your snout you know and that was like
not not the thing are you we hated it
can you look at them now and you know
you really saw these on show one no no I
I'd have to pay you if I did you didn't
know that did you
I I was I remember it very clearly
because when MTV first hit like anyone
might we all all my friends and I just
gather around the TV and would and would
watch it I remembered you had a video
where you had the mirror you had a
mirror chrome scratch play the chrome
scratch plate and I remembered thinking
because I'm a guitar buff that is the
coolest thing in the world and you said
that it actually came in useful to have
a reflective well you can pick out if
you have the chrome scratch first of all
I could always flip the guitar over and
see if my makeup was a mirror yeah yeah
and also I could catch the lights and
you could I could see if there was a
cute guy in the audience I could like
you know watch him all night yeah the
only problem is that if it's an outdoor
venue use outdoor venue you could set
him on fire
that's the cute guy